翻訳: Yohei Shimanuki
校正: Yuri Ueda
みなさん
この 私の ファッションを見て
どんな仕事をしているか
わかりますか？
宇宙飛行士？
(笑)
いや 私はこの地球の上で
ある仕事をしています
そう 養蜂家です
これが 愛する ミツバチの 家です
ミツバチの家ですから
「スイートホーム」
あれ？
(笑)
ですね　(笑)
(ミツバチの羽音)
これが ２万匹のミツバチの羽音です
今日も 元気に お花を 訪ねています
働き蜂は 女の子で その寿命は１ヶ月
一生の間で採る ハチミツの量は
わずかティースプーン１杯です
なのに
ミツバチたちは 私たち生き物のために
大切な役割を してくれています
１日3000箇所のお花を訪ねて
受粉をしてくれているのです
その受粉によって
私たち 生き物の 食べ物が
もたらされています
今日も 元気に お花を訪ねています
ある朝
私はいつものように
ミツバチの園に やってきました
「ミツバチさんおはよう！
今日もよろしくね！」
いつもと変わらない 朝のはずでした
でも 今日は何かが違うのです
私は ハッとして
ミツバチの巣箱を開けてみました
巣箱の中に ミツバチが
一匹もいないのです
どの箱も どの箱も
ミツバチが 一匹もいません
本来なら 秋のハチミツを採るために
ブンブン ブンブン 飛び回っている時期です
そのミツバチの 羽音も ありません
ミツバチの園には
ただ不気味な静けさだけが ありました
ミツバチが 突然 いなくなる―
「蜂群崩壊症候群」
それが 私の目の前で 起きたのです
40万匹のミツバチが いなくなりました
いなくなった ミツバチの 命は
もう二度と帰ってきません
私は ひざの力が がっくりと抜けて
座り込みました
この 蜂群崩壊症候群は
私のミツバチだけに
起こる現象ではありません
今 この瞬間も 世界のどこかで
愛するミツバチを失い
ただ 呆然と立ち尽くす
養蜂家の仲間がいます
みなさん 一緒にイメージしてみてください
もし この世界から
ミツバチが いなくなったら
それでも みなさんと 私は
今までと 何も変わらない
そんな生活ができるでしょうか？
どうですか？
答えは ノーです
ミツバチが 受粉によって
作ってくれた 食べ物が なくなるからです
世界は 食糧危機になります
そもそも 私がミツバチと
出会ったのは ６年前
環境コンサルタントとして
世界中を 飛び回っていた頃です
地球温暖化対策に 取り組んでいた時
毎日 ニュースでは
「気象観測史上初」という言葉が 飛び交い
温暖化は進むばかりでした
「これでいいのだろうか？」
そう自問自答する中
ハードワークも重なり
心も身体も 折れそうになりました
そんな時 ある養蜂場で
ミツバチと出会ったのです
ミツバチの姿
ミツバチの羽音
ミツバチの受粉によって
私たちの食べ物が
もたらされているということ
そのミツバチが
世界中で減っているということ
その事実を 目の当りにした時
私は稲妻に打たれたような衝撃を感じました
「そうだ！
ミツバチを先生にして
みんなに伝えればいい！
そうすれば
みんなが きっと地球に優しい
行動を とれるようになる！」
そう私は 直感したのです
私は ミツバチたちと出会って
人生が豊かになりました
ミツバチが 自然とつなげてくれた事によって
心身ともに 元気になりました
子ども達に
ミツバチを先生とした「ハチ育」を始めました
私のハチ育は
巣箱に来てもらい
ミツバチの「ドゥーン」という
「幸せだぁ」「 安心だぁ」という
羽音を聞いてもらう所から 始まります
その 羽音を聞いた子どもたちは
ざわざわした心が調節されて
穏やかな気持ちになります
ミツバチは ティースプーン一杯の
ハチミツをいただき
何千もの果実を実らせます
その ミツバチの 働きを 知り
自然に感謝の想いが しっかり根付くと
子ども達は
「少しだけいただいて たくさん役に立つ」
つまり
「自分だけが良ければ良い」
というのではなくて
「みんなが幸せになるために」という
思考 言動 行動をとり始めます
こんなお話があります
ハチ育を 受けた子どもが
今まで挑戦した事もなかった
学級委員に立候補しました
公約はこうです
「自分のためじゃなくて
クラスみんなのために
クラスみんなが幸せになるために
僕は頑張ります」
たくさんのライバルの中で
彼は当選したんです
それからもう一つ こんな話もあります
ハチ育を 受けた日の 夕食の食卓で
こんな話をしたそうです
「お父さん お母さん
この食べ物は いったい誰のお陰で
出来ていると思う？
ミツバチさんのお陰なんだよ
ミツバチさんに感謝をして
丁寧に食べなきゃダメだよ」
「まさか うちの子が
こんなしっかりしたことを 親に言うなんて
びっくりしました」
子どもたちは 自然とつながり
その感覚を身につけたときに
本来 自分が持っている
創造力を 蘇らせることができます
そして 自然から
生きる力 人間力を 身につける事が
この ハチ育でわかります
私達 人間は 自然から
たくさんの サービスを 受け取っています
しかし ミツバチと暮らしていて
気付いたことがあります
自然が ミツバチが
少しずつ その生きる力を
弱く しているということです
女王蜂は 本来３年間
卵をたくさん産むのですが
春の１シーズンだけで
もう 卵が産めなくなってしまう
女王蜂がいます
秋に仲間がたくさん増えないことで
冬を越せないミツバチたちがいます
生命力が低下する事で
巣箱に 外敵が 侵入しやすく なっています
蜂群崩壊症候群や
生き物の 生命力の低下によって
今 世界中でミツバチが減っています
全米では 2015年に
ミツバチの42%が 失われました
減少率で考えると あと20年
私たち養蜂家の 肌感覚で言うと
あと10年
ミツバチだけではありません
色んな生き物が いなくなっているのです
私たち人間は
生きていくために 必要な
食べ物も 水も 空気も
何一つ作ることができません
すべて 自然に 依存しているのです
自然を 尊敬して
「共生共栄」する
「共に生きて 共に幸せになる」
これは 今 みなさんと時を同じくする
世界中の 生き物の 願いです
「共生共栄」
「みんなと仲良くして
一緒に生きていきたい」
そんな世界中の生き物の声が
聞こえるように 私には感じます
みなさんから よく こう聞かれます
「私達はいったい何をしたらいいの？」
答えはいつもこうです
自然に感謝をすること
生態系を壊す 農薬を減らすこと
ミツバチが大好きな 花や木を植えること
お買い物をする時に
あなたや ミツバチに優しい
材料 製法で作られた
食品 製品 サービスを
選択しててください　と
ミツバチのために
そして あなた自身のために
自分を愛する生き方を 始めましょう
今残された 自然を しっかり保護しましょう
そして 失いそうな 命を 取り戻しましょう
みなさんが力を合わせれば
自然は きっと帰ってきてくれます
もう あまり時間がありません
これは
人類最大の ピンチです
が
人類最大の チャンスでもあるのです
今までの私たちの あり方を
もう一度 ほどいて
考え直して
行動する時期が 来たのだと
私は感じています
みなさんは どうですか？
今こうしている間にも
ミツバチは たくさんのお花を訪ねて
受粉をしてくれていますし
自然は みなさんに
たくさんの 恩恵を与えてくれています
「共生共栄」
「一緒に幸せになって
一緒にいつまでも暮らしていきたい」
生き物たちの 声です
ミツバチの羽音が
いつまでも 元気に 響く
そんな世界を
みなさんと一緒に
共に作っていきましょう
(ミツバチの羽音)
(拍手)